Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestish said Dr. Ara. I was under the impression that she was asleep. I could not take my eyes away from her breast, because I hoped at any moment to see her arise and the miracle of life repeat itself. Ava was wearing a long white tunic covering her feet. Her hands were visible through the cuffs of white sleeves,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告集锦、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。这就是 therestish 阿拉医生说。我当时以为她睡着了。我的目光无法从她的胸前移开，因为我希望随时能看到她苏醒过来，并看到生命的奇迹再次上演。艾娃穿着一件遮住双脚的白色长袍。她的双手透过白色的袖口露了出来，
and they were knit together, holding a crucifix. Her face was as if of wax, clear and transparent. Her eyes closed as if she was dreaming. Her hair had been beautifully dressed, and she shone with a special radiance. Don't be afraid, said Dr. Ara. She is as whole, intacta as when she was alive. So Dominic, that was creepy husband of the year, Juan Domingo Peron. And that is his memory of his very first visit.
双手紧紧交叠，握着一个十字架。她的面容宛如蜡像般清晰透明。她双眼紧闭，仿佛在做梦。她的头发梳理得十分精美，散发着一种独特的光芒。阿方医生说，不要害怕。她和活着的时候一样完整、无损。所以，多米尼克，这就是年度惊悚丈夫，胡安·多明戈·庇隆。这就是他对第一次探访的记忆。
I think the first of three visits to see the embalmed corpse of his late wife, Ava Evita, a year after she had died in 1952. And we've promised people mad scenes in this episode. And I guess that's quite a mad scene. But what I will tell the listeners is it's going to get a whole lot madder, isn't it? Because we're dealing today with the afterlife of Ava Perron, and particularly what happens to this mummified body of hers. And the story is just spectacularly odd. It is very odd. So we ended last time, if you remember, with the extraordinary grief, the sort of, what do they call it, a bacchanal of necrophilia that pair on critics.
我想这是三次探访中的第一次，去瞻仰他已故妻子艾娃·埃维塔那具防腐处理的遗体，那是在她于1952年去世一年后。我们在这一集里向大家承诺过疯狂的场景。我想这确实是一个相当疯狂的场景。但我要告诉听众的是，接下来会变得更加疯狂，对吧？因为我们今天讨论的是艾娃·庇隆死后的故事，尤其是她的这具木乃伊发生了什么。这个故事简直离奇得惊人。确实非常离奇。所以上期节目结束时，如果你还记得的话，那种无与伦比的悲伤，那种被庇隆的批评者们称为……
Yeah. So the problem I have with this episode is that there's a brilliant novel, I mean, very creepy, weird novel by an Argentine writer called Tomas Martinez, which came out in 1996. So the same year as the Madonna musical, the film, and it was called Santa Evita. And it tells the story of this, everything that happens. And I was going through your notes and it seemed to me that certain bits were missing, as it were, from your story, not from the body of Evita, obviously, because the novel portrays itself as being strictly factual. But I'm suspecting that he may actually have elaborated, he may have fabricated
对，所以我对这一集的一个问题是，有一部非常精彩的小说，我是说一部非常惊悚、诡异的小说，由一位名叫托马斯·马丁内斯的阿根廷作家于1996年出版。所以和麦当娜的音乐剧、电影是同一年，书名叫《圣埃维塔》。它讲述了这个故事以及发生的一切。我当时在看你的笔记，觉得从你的故事里似乎漏掉了一些片段，当然不是指埃维塔的遗体，因为小说本身声称完全基于事实。但我怀疑他可能真的进行了润色，他可能虚构了
certain things. There are layers upon layers of myth, folk tales, legends, weird propaganda tales, and all that. So I might, as we go through, I might just see what you think of. Yeah, throw in some stuff that's not true, Tom. We always like that on The Rest is History. Well, you can evaluate it. It'll be a test of your methodology as a historian. But I mean, even without it, I mean, what we know and what can be attested is pretty bizarre. This is the story of Evita's ghost and what it meant for Argentina. And you could argue that Argentina in the next 20, 30 years
某些内容。这里面有层层叠叠的神话、民间故事、传说、离奇的宣传故事等等。所以随着我们的深入，我可能会看看你的看法。没错，加点不真实的内容吧，汤姆。我们在《历史的余烬》里一向很喜欢这样。好吧，你可以评估一下。这将是对你作为历史学家的方法论的一次考验。不过我的意思是，即便没有这些，我们所知道且有据可查的事实也已经足够离奇了。这就是埃维塔的幽灵以及它对阿根廷意味着什么的故事。你可以说，在接下来的20、30年里，阿根廷
is going to go through a very strange necrophiliac kind of politics. So we'll start with the body. The body, as we ended last time, has got to the headquarters of the trade unions, the CGT. And as we said, Dr. Pedro Ara, the guy who at the beginning.
将经历一种非常诡异的恋尸癖式的政治。所以我们从遗体开始讲起。正如我们上期节目结束时所说的那样，这具遗体已经被送到了工会总部，即劳工总联合会（CGT）。正如我们所说，皮德罗·阿拉医生，也就是开头提到的那个人。
With the head of the embalmed peasant in his briefcase. Yeah, the guy who you said was saying, don't be afraid. He has built a secret laboratory on the third floor of this building. And he now takes possession of the body, which of course is not in the state that he had hoped. She has been literally lying in state too long. So I'll read to you into the distance what Dr. Ara did. He made incisions in the heels and below the neck by which the body was drained was then placed in a bath of 150 liters of acetate and potassium nitrate which was weighted down and it was weighted down with a coffin lid to keep it
手里提着那个做过防腐处理的农夫脑袋。没错，就是那个你说的当时在说“不要害怕”的人。他在这个大楼的三楼建立了一个秘密实验室。现在他接管了遗体，当然，这具遗体并没有达到他所希望的状态。她躺在灵堂里的时间实在是太久了。所以我给你们读一下阿拉医生当年具体做了什么。他在脚后跟和颈部下方切开切口，将体内的液体排出，然后将其浸泡在150升醋酸和硝酸钾的混合液浴中，上面压上棺盖以使其保持
under the surface then it was injected and re-injected with mixtures of formal thymol and pure alcohol dipped in bath after bath month after after month, re-injected each time and finally coated with a thin but hard layer of transparent plastic so that it could be displayed and touched. So if anybody listening to this has ever been to see the body of Lenin in Red Square, you will know that it looks very weird and waxy. And I would imagine that this must have had a similar process, although in Lenin's case, the process, I believe, is still secret. Arra does this for a year, and it must have looked, at the end of it, very waxy and very shop dummy. And it costs a lot of money, doesn't
在液面以下，接着用甲醛、百里酚和纯酒精的混合物进行反复注射，一个月又一个月地在一缸又一缸的药液中浸泡，每次浸泡后重新注射，最后涂上一层薄而硬的透明塑料，以便人们可以展示和触摸。所以，如果听这个节目的任何人曾经去红场瞻仰过列宁的遗体，你就会知道它看起来非常诡异，像蜡像一样。我想这一定经过了类似的工艺，不过就列宁而言，据我所知，防腐工艺至今仍是个秘密。阿拉做了一年，到最后，这具遗体看起来一定非常像蜡像和商店里的塑料模特。而且花了很多钱，
it? It's kind of $100,000. It's an absolutely crazy thing to do. After a year, he says to the government, the Argentine government to Peron's government, the body is now stable. It is under a glass case, but this must not be opened. And I have the key. Only I have the key. Now, the reason that it's still there and he is keeping the key is that the tomb that they have been preparing for Eva Peron is not ready. Now, the plan for the tomb is mad.
对吧？大约10万美元。这绝对是一件疯狂至极的事情。一年后，他对政府、阿根廷政府、庇隆政府说，遗体现在已经稳定了。它被放在玻璃罩下，但这绝不能打开。我有钥匙。只有我有钥匙。现在，之所以它还留在那里而他保留着钥匙，是因为他们一直在为埃娃·庇隆准备的陵墓还没有建好。陵墓的计划简直疯狂。
It's going to be a colossal monument, sort of ultra the fatherland monument, the biggest in Argentina. It's modeled on Napoleon's tomb, I think. It is. And it will be topped with a gigantic 60 meter tall statue of a desk with this shirt undone, sort of like Peter Frankopan, the historian, Tom shirt unbuttoned to the navel, standing there, a sort of image of unrepentant masculinity. I hope Peter commissions a statue like that for his grave.
这将是一座宏伟的纪念碑，某种超级祖国纪念碑，阿根廷最大的纪念碑。它的蓝图似乎是仿照拿破仑的陵墓建造的。确实如此。它顶端将耸立着一座高达60米的巨型无衫汉（Descamisado）雕像，衬衫领口敞开，有点像历史学家彼得·弗兰科潘，汤姆，衬衫扣子一直解到肚脐眼，站在那里，仿佛是不知悔改的男子气概的化身。我希望彼得能为自己的墓地定制这样一座雕像。
Oh, it looks tremendous. The statue, well, I'm trying to understand really how the statue would work. But what seems to be clear is there would be a lift inside this bloke. So you would get the lift up through his legs or something to his head and then you'd come out in his head you'd be able to look out through his eyes over the skyscape of buenos aires now unbelievably this plan is bonkers but the committee the official government committee said to the the sculptor who was called leon tomasi actually have changed our minds i think it should be of her he said oh no no she would look. The proportions would all be wrong. And they agree.
哦，看起来太壮观了。这座雕像，好吧，我一直在试图理解这座雕像到底该怎么运作。但似乎很清楚的一点是，这个大块头内部会有一部电梯。所以你可以乘电梯穿过他的双腿或什么的到达他的头部，然后你就会从他的头部出来，能够透过他的眼睛俯瞰布宜诺斯艾利斯的城市风光。现在，难以置信的是，这个计划荒谬绝伦，但官方政府委员会却对雕塑家雷昂·托马西说，其实我们改变主意了，我觉得应该做成她的样子。他说，哦不，不，她看起来……
The committee says, well, we'll compromise. You will still have the Descamisado bloke, the shirtless bloke on top of the monument. But let us get Dr. Ara. This is my favorite detail. To embalm four more bodies, which will act as kind of, and we'll have them standing upright. So they're going to embalm a descamisado. So I don't know whether they kill him first. And a member of each of the armed forces.
比例全都不对。他们竟然同意了。委员会说，好吧，我们折中一下。纪念碑顶端依然保留那个无衫汉，那个光着膀子的家伙。但让我们请阿拉医生——这是我最喜欢的细节——把另外四具尸体也做成防腐处理，作为某种陪衬，而且我们要让他们站立着。所以他们打算给一个无衫汉做防腐处理——我不知道他们是不是先把他弄死了——以及武装部队的每个兵种各选一人。
You can kind of imagine the pharaonic planning committee kind of working out, oh, why don't we build a pyramid? That's a great idea. Let's go for that. I guess you could say, if you wanted to make a serious point, it was a sign of how autocratic authoritarian regimes work, is that in the committee meetings people are just competing to offer ever more radical and demented ideas to please the authorities so it's actually dr ara who says yeah i can't do this but he says i couldn't possibly do four more i don't have enough resources i would need more
你大概可以想象那个法老式的规划委员会在筹划时那种心情：哦，我们为什么不建一座金字塔呢？这主意真棒。就选这个吧。我想你可以说，如果你想表达一个严肃的观点，这就是极权威权政体运作方式的一个写照：在委员会会议上，人们只是在争相提出更加激进和疯狂的主意来取悦当权者。所以实际上是阿拉医生说，是的，我干不了这个，但他说，我绝不可能再做四个，我的资源不够，我需要更多的
assistance i would need this a year after death 1953 they have gone nowhere. So where Evita is, she is in Dr. Ara's laboratory at the CGT. They've set up a makeshift funeral chapel with sort of lights and a crucifix. And Peron is given a private lift up from the basement. Now, some people actually say he only went to see it once, but he certainly doesn't go more than three times. Well, it's creepy. I was about to say that. I mean, you know, don't blame him. Would you be hanging around with it? I mean, that would be more weird. Anyway, the cult of Evita, meanwhile, outside the building is absolutely going strong. On the 22nd of every month, the anniversary of her death, there are huge torchlight processions through Buenos Aires. Then on the first anniversary of her death, the newspaper La Prensa, formerly
协助，我需要这个。死后一年，即1953年，他们毫无进展。至于埃维塔在哪里，她在工会总部阿拉医生的实验室里。他们临时搭建了一个简陋的灵堂，配有某种灯光和十字架。庇隆有专属电梯可以直接从地下室上去。现在，实际上有人说他只去看过一次，但他绝对去的次数不超过三次。这太诡异了。我正想这么说。我的意思是，你知道的，别怪他。你会一直在那儿闲逛吗？我的意思是，那才更诡异呢。无论如何，与此同时，大楼外面的埃维塔崇拜活动正如火如荼地进行着。每个月的22日，也就是她逝世的纪念日，布宜诺斯艾利斯都会举行大规模的火炬游行。然后在她逝世一周年之际，《新闻报》——曾是一份精英阶层的报纸，但随后被庇隆政权接管——刊登了一则报道，上面写着，
a newspaper of the elite, but which has subsequently been taken over by the Peronist regime, prints a story and it says, amazing news, Evita's face has been seen in the moon. Of course it has. And after this, there are endless sightings that people can see her face in the stars. And kind of looking like the Virgin. She now has become conflated with the Virgin. There have been kind of demands for her to be canonized, haven't there, immediately in the wake of her death. That lots of people write into the Vatican. And they, obviously, I mean, the Vatican don't want to have her as a saint.
令人惊奇的消息，人们在月亮上看到了埃维塔的面容。当然会有了。在此之后，出现了无数的目击事件，人们宣称在星星上看到了她的脸。而且看起来有点像圣母。她现在已经与圣母混为一谈了。在她逝世后不久，社会上甚至立即出现了将她册封为圣徒的呼声，对吧？许多人写信给梵蒂冈。而他们，很明显，梵蒂冈并不想把她奉为圣徒。
But they kind of weasel out of it by saying, well, she hasn't done a miracle. But the Peronist regime have prayers to her effectively nonetheless. By 1953, you are taught this in schools. Our little mother, thou who art in heaven, good fairy laughing among the angels. Evita, I promise to be as good as you wish me to be, respecting God, loving my country, taking care of General Peron, studying and being towards everyone the child you dreamed I would be, healthy, happy, well-educated, and pure in heart. Isn't that nice?
但他们用一种狡猾的方式搪塞过去，说她还没有显现过神迹。尽管如此，庇隆政权实际上仍然有针对她的祈祷文。到了1953年，你在学校里就会被教导这些。我们的慈母，你在天之灵，在天使中欢笑的好仙女。埃维塔，我答应像你所希望的那样做一个好孩子，尊重上帝，热爱祖国，照顾庇隆将军，努力学习，并在所有人面前做那个你梦想中我应成为的孩子：健康、快乐、受过良好教育且心地纯洁。这难道不是很美好吗？
So if you're a Catholic priest, you are probably quite perturbed by all this. Peron, we'll get to Peron in the Catholic Church in a second, but Peron, he's quite a lonely figure at this point. So he's quite isolated at the top of his regime. I'm trying to be nice to him, Tom, because it's fair to say he lets himself down. Would you agree with that? I mean, I think he lets Evita down. I think he lets Argentina down. But I think worst of all, he very much lets himself down. He does. He now has to play both parts. So we talked before about the political significance of Eva Perón was that in a society where obviously women have just been given the vote,
所以如果你是一名天主教神父，你大概会对此感到相当不安。庇隆，我们一会儿再谈庇隆与天主教的关系，但庇隆，他在这个时候是个相当孤独的人物。所以在他的政权顶端，他相当孤立。我正试图对他说好话，汤姆，因为平心而论，他确实让人失望了。你同意这个看法吗？我的意思是，我认为他让埃维塔失望了。我认为他让阿根廷失望了。但我认为最糟糕的是，他非常彻底地让自己失望了。他确实如此。他现在必须扮演两个角色。所以我们之前谈过，埃娃·庇隆的政治意义在于，在一个妇女刚刚获得选举权的社会里，
she can appeal to a different constituency from Peron and do things that he can't do. And he's now having to play both roles and slightly take over her foundation. At the beginning, Peronism is very kind of freeform. Nobody's quite sure where it's going. That's part of the fun of it. And Evita is obviously brilliant at that. But with her gone, it's all becoming a bit formal, a bit ponderous, a bit clumsy. And that kind of spark of charisma has just gone. And also he has to make choices. So he has to make political
她可以吸引到与庇隆不同的选民群体，并能做一些他做不到的事情。而现在，他不得不一人分饰两角色，并且还要稍微接管她的基金会。起初，庇隆主义是非常自由散漫的。没有人十分确定它将走向何方。这也是其中的乐趣所在。埃维塔在这方面显然才华横溢。但随着她的离去，这一切都变得有点形式化、有点笨重、有点生硬。那种充满魅力的火花已经消失了。而且他也必须做出抉择。所以他必须做出政治
choices. And whereas before he could make those choices and she could do all the rhetorical stuff, now he has to do both, especially when times are tougher and there are hard economic choices. It's being reduced much more to the kind of nuts and bolts of ordinary politics. But Dominic, what is it that he specifically does that lets everyone down? Okay. So yeah, one of his ministers says to him, you should cheer yourself up by doing a very Eva Perón friendly thing. Why don't we set up a union de estudiantes secundarios, union of secondary school students. Perón says, brilliant. He says, actually, actually you know what my summer home at olivos i don't actually use that that much so you could use part of the grounds athletics for the kids great and he supposedly said initially as a joke wouldn't it be nice you know bring the girls down get them to do their athletics and of course in a kind of authoritarian regime when the
抉择。以前他可以做出那些抉择，而她则负责所有雄辩浮夸的言辞，现在他必须两者兼顾，特别是当时代变得更加艰难、需要做出严峻的经济抉择时。政治已经被大大简化为普通政治的那些日常琐事。但是，多米尼克，他究竟做了什么具体的事让所有人都失望了呢？好吧。所以，是的，他的一位部长对他说，你应该做一件非常讨埃娃·庇隆喜欢的事来让自己振作起来。我们为什么不成立一个中学生联合会（Union de Estudiantes Secundarios）呢？庇隆说，太棒了。他说，其实，其实你知道吗，我在奥利沃斯的度假别墅我其实不怎么常用，所以你可以用一部分场地给孩子们做田径运动，太棒了。他最初大概是开玩笑地说，不是很棒吗，把女孩子们带过来，让她们做做田径运动。当然，在一个威权政权里，当
guy says it yeah so the next thing you know there were all these pubescent girls in very short shorts kind of doing gymnastics outside perron's bedroom window and he is absolutely delighted by this in 1955 a romanian writer went off to write a biography he said basically perron spent all his time standing at his window staring out at these girls perron would come every day to look at them. It was a very lovely sight. Now, at this point, it's pure, you know, sometimes people saying he's not going to work as much as he used to because he's just hanging around staring at these girls. Is it felt at the time to be pervy? Don't forget, he set up the Union of Secondary School Students. So him being with the youth of Argentina, you know, that's what dictators always
那个人这么说时，是的。所以接下来你知道的，所有这些正值青春期的女孩穿着非常短的短裤在庇隆的卧室窗外做体操。而对此他感到绝对欣喜若狂。1955年，一位罗马尼亚作家去写传记，他说基本上庇隆把所有时间都花在站在窗前凝视这些女孩上，庇隆每天都会来看她们。这是一个非常可爱的景象。现在，在这个时候，这纯粹是，你知道，有时人们说他不打算像以前那样工作了，因为他只是四处闲逛盯着这些女孩。当时人们觉得这很猥琐吗？别忘了，他成立了中学生联合会。所以他跟阿根廷的年轻人在一起，你知道，独裁者总是这么干。
do. I mean, now that would be political death for any political leader to spend his time gawping at schoolgirls exercising. But at the time, is it felt to be a bit odd? Or is it just, oh, bless him, he's invested in the youth of Argentina? The version that's presented to most people is not odd. But it does then go a bit odd, doesn't it? He would invite some of the girls to lunch during the summer when he's working at the summer residence and one of these girls is a
我的意思是，现在任何政治领导人如果把时间都花在盯着女学生锻炼上，那在政治上就彻底完蛋了。但在当时，人们觉得这有点诡异吗？还是说大家只会觉得，噢，上帝保佑他，他很关心阿根廷的青年？呈现给大多数人的版本并不觉得诡异。但后来事情确实变得有点诡异了，对吧？当他在夏宫工作时，夏天他会邀请一些女孩共进午餐，其中有个女孩是一个
janitor's daughter who is called nelly revas and she becomes a bit of a regular at perron's lunch table she and he at this point is 58 or something and she is 14 and one day they have lunch and you know they talk and they find they've got a lot in common and they talk long into the night. And Perron says, well, I mean, you know, it's dark and cold. Why don't you stay the night, my dear? A week later, he goes to see the boxing matches at Luna Park and he decides to invite Nellie with him. So she comes. Because Dominic, just to remind listeners, the girlfriend he had before Evita, the piranha. She was 17 and he introduced her as his daughter, remember.
看门人的女儿，名叫内莉·里瓦斯（Nelly Rivas），她成了庇隆午餐桌上的常客。此时他已经58岁左右了，而她才14岁。有一天他们共进午餐，你知道的，他们聊天，发现彼此有很多共同点，一直聊到深夜。庇隆说，好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，天又黑又冷。亲爱的，你为什么不留下来过夜呢？一周后，他去月神公园看拳击比赛，并决定邀请内莉同去。所以她也去了。因为多米尼克，提醒一下听众，他在埃维塔之前交往的女朋友，那个食人鱼。她才17岁，他当时介绍说那是他的女儿，还记得吗？
So I think it's fair to say, Tom, that we have now entered quite murky waters. And many listeners may rightly be quite harsh on Piranha. I think he has let himself down. However, on the positive side, as he had done with Evita, so now with Nelly, he does introduce her to the biographies of Plutarch, his favorite writer. This is the bizarre thing. So Nelly later on said, he got me a private tutor.
所以我想说句公道话，汤姆，我们现在已经进入了相当混浊的水域。许多听众可能会理所当然地对庇隆给出相当严厉的评价。我认为他确实让自己失望了。不过从积极的方面来看，就像他对埃维塔做的那样，现在对内莉也是如此，他确实向她引荐了他最喜欢的作家普鲁塔克的传记。这才是最诡异的地方。所以内莉后来回忆说，他给我找了一个私人教师。
He encouraged me to read Plutarch. We know that he wrote letters to her where he signed himself Daddy. His nickname for her was Tinolita, which was also the name that he called one of his poodles. So read into that what you will. I think it is pretty clear, Tom, that they did have a physical relationship because after his downfall, there was a kind of investigation and Nelly herself is supposed to have testified that they did have this relationship. So listen, people can make up their own minds about Peron's, I think, very poor behavior. Meanwhile, Argentina is getting itself into a terrible economic mess and arguably one from which it never, ever recovers. So the balance of its trade is against it. Basically, it's not
他鼓励我阅读普鲁塔克。我们知道他写给她的信中自称为“爸爸”。他对她的昵称是“蒂诺利塔”（Tinolita），这也是他给自己的其中一只贵宾犬取的名字。所以大家从中体会吧。我认为很明显，汤姆，他们确实有过肉体关系，因为在他倒台后，曾进行过某种调查，内莉本人也被认为曾作证承认他们确实有过这种关系。所以听着，大家可以对庇隆极其糟糕的行为做出自己的判断。与此同时，阿根廷陷入了可怕的经济困境，可以说是一个从此再也无法恢复的困境。所以它的贸易收支呈现逆差。基本上，它从出口（牛肉等）中赚取的钱已经不够了，
making enough money anymore from its exports, from its beef and whatnot, and it is importing too much from abroad, things that it's not manufacturing itself, and it's paying for them with dollars and pounds that it just doesn't have. Argentina, as we have said, was a very rich country in the first half of the 20th century. People are used to being rich. And effectively, what happens is successive governments don't want to or can't persuade people that they're not going to be as rich in the future. So they just print money. And so from the 1950s, 1960s, 1970s, you start to get extremely high inflation. So terrible leader and collapsing economy. I mean, thank God that wouldn't happen here. Well, I mean, Peron deals with this in a way that will be very familiar
而它从海外进口的商品又太多了——那些它自己没有制造的东西，并且它用自己根本没有的美洲元和英镑来支付这些费用。正如我们所说，在20世纪的上半叶，阿根廷曾是一个非常富裕的国家。人们已经习惯了富有。实际上，发生的情况是，历届政府都不愿意或者无法让人们相信，他们在未来不会像过去那么富有了。所以他们只能印钱。因此，从20世纪50年代、60年代、70年代开始，你开始经历极其严重的通货膨胀。所以，糟糕的领导人和崩溃的经济。我的意思是，谢天谢地，这种事不会在这里发生。好吧，我的意思是，庇隆处理这件事的方式，对于研究过任何威权政体的人来说都会非常熟悉。
to people who've studied any kind of authoritarian regime. He starts to lash out. So most famously, in 1953, there's a big rally he has with his union supporters. Bombs go off at this rally. Peron kind of loses it and says, we're going to have to go back to the days when we walked around with garrots in our pockets. And then the crowds swarm through the city. They sack the offices of socialist and radical party groups. Why? Because they're not socialists and radicals. The socialists and radicals are Peron's opponents. I mean, this is the weird thing. Peronism is this big, ambiguous populist movement, big tent, and they attack both sort of Marxist groups on the left, but they also head for the jockey club, the bastion of kind of Anglophile, pro-British, old elites, you know, polo playing,
他开始大打出手。最典型的是，在1953年，他与工会支持者举行了一场大型集会。集会上发生了爆炸。庇隆有点情绪失控，说道，我们将不得不回到那种口袋里揣着加勒特绞索四处游荡的日子。随后，人群蜂拥穿过城市。他们洗劫了社会主义者和激进党派团体的办公室。为什么？因为他们不是社会主义者和激进者。社会主义者和激进者是庇隆的反对派。我的意思是，这就是诡异的地方：庇隆主义是一个庞大、含糊不清的民粹主义运动，一个包罗万象的大帐篷，他们既攻击左翼的马克思主义团体，同时也直奔赛马俱乐部——那里是亲英、亲英国的旧精英阶层的大本营，打马球，
all of that stuff. They set fire to it. They sack it. I mean, this is a big moment in Buenos Aires' history. And they destroy a Goya and a Velázquez, don't they? Yes, exactly. I mean, it is a sign of the ideological incoherence of Peronism that they attack both the socialist buildings and the kind of English gentleman's club. So that's one wing of Peronism, the Descamisados. But what about the army? Are they getting out the sunglasses by this stage and dusting down the electrodes and looking for poets and that kind of thing? numbers. Police had, by the way, always used cattle prods on suspected felons, on criminals. But now for the first time, they're using them on political opponents of the regime. And that is a very ominous moment for Argentina. The arrival of the cattle prod as a kind of political prop, it's a path from which they will find it very difficult to turn. So Perón also,
以及所有那一套东西。他们放火烧了它。他们洗劫了它。我的意思是，这是布宜诺斯艾利斯历史上的一个重大时刻。他们还毁了一幅戈雅和一幅委拉斯凯兹的名画，对吧？是的，完全如此。我的意思是，这正是庇隆主义意识形态不连贯的标志，他们既袭击社会主义者的建筑，又袭击英国绅士俱乐部。所以这是庇隆主义的一个翼，即无衫汉们。但是军队呢？在这个阶段，他们是不是已经拿出了墨镜，掸掉电击棒上的灰尘，开始寻找诗人们下手了？数量。顺便说一句，警察以前对涉嫌重罪的嫌疑人和罪犯一直使用电牛棒。但现在他们第一次将其用在了政权的政治反对派身上。对于阿根廷来说，这是一个非常不祥的时刻。电牛棒作为一种政治道具的出现，是一条他们将发现极难回头的道路。所以庇隆还，
the other big thing he does, we mentioned the Catholic Church, Perón takes on the Catholic Church. I mean, that seems mad. Why is he doing that? Do you know what? Historians don't really agree about that. There's a healthy debate about that. Some people say it's because his ambition is to have a totalitarian Peronist society. I don't think he really did actually. And the church is an obstacle to that. There's some people who actually say it's actually because of the thing about the secondary school students, because the Catholic church had previously run education and been in charge
另一件大事，我们提到了天主教教会，庇隆向天主教教会宣战了。我的意思是，这看起来太疯狂了。他为什么要这么做？你知道吗？历史学家对此并没有真正的共识。对此有着一场健康的辩论。有人说是因为他的野心是建立一个极权主义的庇隆主义社会。我觉得他其实并没有这种想法。而教会是实现这一目标的一个障碍。还有人说，实际上是因为中学生的事，因为天主教教会以前一直负责教育，并掌管着
of youth groups and all that kind of thing. And they're a competitor with his Peronist groups. And basically the confrontation gets completely out of hand. They're all demonstrations and counter demonstrations. He blames two Catholic priests in particular and basically kicks them out of the country. And in response to that, the Vatican excommunicates him. So very kind of medieval scenes. By this point, the Vatican isn't making a habit of excommunicates him. So very kind of medieval scenes. By this point, the Vatican isn't making a habit of excommunicating.
青年团体以及所有类似的事情。他们构成了对他的庇隆主义团体的竞争。基本上这场对抗彻底失控了。到处都是游行和反游行。他特别指责了两名天主教神父，并基本上把他们驱逐出了国。作为回应，梵蒂冈将他逐出了教会。所以可以说是相当中世纪的场景。到了这个时候，梵蒂冈可不会把逐出教会当成家常便饭。不。这是自1890年以来首次发生这种事。我的意思是，他是一个容易下手的目标，对吧？我的意思是，你不会去把哈罗德·麦克米伦逐出教会，因为对梵蒂冈来说，找阿根廷的麻烦要容易得多，我想是这样的。所以庇隆被逐出了教会。我想问题在于，如果埃维塔还在，会对这一切有所不同吗？许多庇隆主义者认为会的，并一直辩称如果她活着，这一切就不会发生。庇隆的传记作家约瑟夫·佩奇（Joseph Page）说，其实是有可能的，她本可能会带来不同，因为庇隆主义核心的那种角色分工——他负责理智、务实的政治，或者至少对庇隆主义者来说是理智的。她负责那些夸张的辞令和戏剧化的表现。但在天主教的意义上，埃维塔曾称庇隆为黑暗中上帝的面容，
No. It's the first time it's happened since 1890. I mean, he's an easy target, right? I mean, you wouldn't excommunicate Harold Macmillan because Argentina is kind of easy for the Vatican to pick a fight with, I would say. So Peron's been excommunicated. The question, I guess, is would Evita have made a difference to all this? Many Peronists think so, and always argued that if she'd lived, this wouldn't have happened. Peron's biographer, Joseph Page, says it is possible, actually, she would have made a difference because the division of roles that is at the heart of Peronism, he does the sensible, pragmatic politics, or sensible to Peronists anyway. She does the rhetorical excesses and the melodrama. But in the Catholic sense, Evita had called Peron the face of God in the darkness,
这意味着她将作为圣母在上帝和罪人之间扮演这种居中调解的角色。对于政权的运作来说，这其实相当重要，不是吗？没错，确实如此。我认为它的运作方式是，她负责所有戏剧化的极端表现。而他扮演仁慈的君王、调停者。随着她的离去，他必须两者兼顾。而在那个政权里，你不可能两者兼顾。而且他又不能让内莉来做这事，对吧？不，他不能让内莉来做。所以在1955年9月，此前夏天曾发生过一次失败的政变，当时他们在布宜诺斯艾利斯市中心投掷了大量炸弹。我的意思是，那次政变非常盛大，我必须得说。
which means that she would have this mediating role as the Virgin between God and the sinner. And that was kind of quite important, wasn't it, for the functioning of the regime? Exactly, it was. I think the way it worked was that she did all the sort of melodramatic excesses. He played the benevolent monarch, the moderator. And with her gone, he has to do both. And you can't do both in that regime. And he can't get Nelly to do it, can he? No, he can't get Nelly to do it. So in September 1955, there'd been one previous coup that failed in the summer when they dropped a lot of bombs on the center of Buenos Aires. I mean, that coup is a very extravagant, I have to say.
科尔多瓦（科尔多瓦是布宜诺斯艾利斯以西的一座城市）的军队发生了一场叛乱。我的意思是，他们的政变非常盛大，我必须得说。科尔多瓦（科尔多瓦是布宜诺斯艾利斯以西的一座城市）的军队发生了一场叛乱，而庇隆，你知道的，他并不是一个特别暴力的人。他本可以反击的。许多人认为他在经过一番苦战后实际上本可以镇压这场政变。但他选择了，他由衷地选择了不这样做。你知道，有些人愿意为他战死，
There's a revolt by army units in Cordoba, which is a city to the west of Buenos Aires. I mean, their coups are very extravagant, I have to say. There's a revolt by army units in Cordoba, which is a city to the west of Buenos Aires. And Perón, you know, he's not an especially violent man. He could have fought back. A lot of people think he could actually have suppressed the coup after a lot of fighting. But he chooses, he genuinely chooses not to. You know, there are people who are willing to fight for him,
但他却说，不，我受够了。我无心恋战。我想他其实真的很享受扮演国家之父的角色。归根结底，他的心思并不在于做一个好斗的、具有分裂性的——你知道的——做弗朗哥将军那样的人。我的意思是，他曾在西班牙内战期间去过西班牙，不是吗？或者在那之后不久。是的，而且被他所看到的一切震惊了。是的。在音乐剧中，有一个场景是埃维塔劝说他，坚持下去。你绝不能放弃。而他则某种程度上说，你知道，噢，我们可以放弃这一切，去露台上啜饮鸡尾酒。你认为
but he says, no, I've had enough. My heart's not in it. I think he actually really enjoyed playing the father of his country. And ultimately, his heart wasn't in being a divisive, aggressive, you know, being General Franco. I mean, he'd been to Spain in the Civil War, hadn't he? Or shortly afterwards. Yeah. And being appalled by what he'd seen. Yeah. In the musical, there is a scene where Evita is kind of saying, stick with it. You mustn't give up. And he's kind of saying, you know, oh, we could give it up, you know, sipping cocktails on a terrace. Do you think
这里面有这样一种成分吗？音乐剧在那里捕捉到了他性格中的某个方面吗？我认为确实有一点成分。我的意思是，他在接下来的差不多20家里确实是在露台上啜饮鸡尾酒，而且看起来对此并不怎么不快。我猜蒂姆·莱斯（Tim Rice）在那里就是借鉴了这一点。我可以在巴拉圭找到工作满意度。是的，没错，他确实做到了。所以那一刻，对于阿根廷来说，当他被赶下台的那一刻，有一位名叫埃尔内斯托·萨巴托（Ernesto Sabato）的阿根廷作家对此写过一段精彩的文字，
there's an element of that as the musical picked on an aspect of his character there? I think there is a bit of an element. I mean, he does sip cocktails on a terrace for basically the next 20 years and doesn't seem too displeased by it. Which I assume is what Tim Rice is drawing on there for that kind of thing. I could find job satisfaction in Paraguay. Yeah, well, he does. So that moment, though, for Argentina, that moment when he's kicked out, there's a brilliant passage about this by an Argentine writer called Ernesto Sabato,
他当时在北部城市萨尔塔附近。萨巴托说，他当时正和医生、作家以及其他精英阶层的人待在一座豪华房子的起居室里。他们在庆祝庇隆的倒台，因为他们一直痛恨庇隆。他说他总是记得，在厨房的角落里，我看到两个在厨房工作的印第安妇女，她们的眼里浸满了泪水。他说他当时意识到，会有千千万万像这样的人——像这些可贫苦的妇女或原住民等等——当别人在庆祝时，她们却在哭泣，
who was then in the northern city of Salta near. And Sabato says he's in the living room with this posh house with kind of doctors and writers and other elite people. And they are celebrating peron's fall because they always hated peron and he says he always remembered that in the corner of the kitchen i saw how two indian women who worked in the kitchen had their eyes drenched with tears and he said he realized at that moment there would be millions of people like that like these poor women or indigenous people or whatever who would be crying while they were
因为在阿根廷整个历史上，庇隆是唯一一个为她们做过实事的人。我认为，这就是为什么当庇隆倒台时，这并不像其他任何独裁者被赶下台那样。对许多人来说，他并非一个暴君。他和埃娃是曾经给过他们孤儿院、学校、养老金以及所有这些东西的人。正因如此，当他下台后，他们甚至制定了法律，规定你不能直呼他们的名字，家里不能挂他们的照片，所有这一切都是非法的。你知道，她建立的所有各种组织都被取消和禁止了。他们确实感到有必要彻底抹去关于他们的记忆。
celebrating because Perón was the only person who had ever done anything for them in all Argentina's history. And that is, I think, why when Perón goes, it's not just like any other dictator being kicked out. So a lot of people, he had not been a tyrant. He and Eva had been the people who had given them, you know, orphanages, schools, pensions, all of these kinds of things. Which is why when he goes, they kind of institute legislation, don't they, saying that you can't mention them by name, that you can't have pictures of them in your house, that all this is illegal. You know, all the various organisations that she set up get cancelled and banned. They really feel a need to extirpate the very memory of them.
当然，庇隆现在已经去了巴拉圭。他一到那里，就给内莉写了一封信。我想念我的小女孩和贵宾犬。不久我就会派人接你，我们俩将过上平静的生活。你是我的一切，是我留下的唯一挚爱。你可以想象我一整天都在想你。替我照顾好贵宾犬。你爸爸的深情一吻。我的意思是，人们可能又会对此挑起眉毛。问题是，庇隆根本没等她。他溜去了巴拿马。几个月内，另一个女人就吸引了他的目光。她是一名歌舞表演舞者。她原名叫玛丽亚·埃斯特拉·马丁内斯（Maria Estela Martinez）。
Of course, Peron, he has now gone to Paraguay. When he gets there, he writes a letter to Nelly. I miss my little girl and the poodles. Soon I will send for you and the two of us will have a quiet life. You're all I have, the only beloved thing left for me. You can imagine I think of you all day long. Take care of the poodles for me. A big kiss from your daddy. I mean, people may, again, rather raise an eyebrow at that. The thing is, Perron doesn't wait for her. He buggers off to Panama. And within months, another woman has caught his eye. She's a cabaret dancer. Her original name was Maria Estela Martinez.
她24岁，所以比他年轻得多。但她自称为“伊莎贝尔”。现在，她看起来似乎是一个非常善良、温柔的人。她喜欢跳舞和音乐。我读到过，据说她的两大爱好是谈论医学和吃蜂蜜。她有一个稍微有点奇怪的兴趣，这在后来的这个故事中会非常重要。作为一个十几岁的小姑娘，她曾寄宿在一对非常迷恋神秘学和精神主义的夫妇家里。她也深深地迷上了这些。并且她把前妻的名字作为自己的艺名，
She's 24, so she's a lot younger than him as well. But she calls herself Isabel. Now, she just seems to be a very nice, sweet person. She likes dancing and music. Her twin passions, I read, were said to be talking about medicine and eating honey. She has a slightly odd interest, which will be very important later on in this story. As a teenager, she had lodged with a couple who were really into the occult and spiritualism. And she had got really into it as well. And she had taken, as her stage
给自己取名为伊莎贝尔。所以这就是伊莎贝尔。伊莎贝尔极度痴迷于精神主义。当她在跳完舞后遇到庇隆时，她正在读一本关于佛教的书。而他只是觉得，啊，这是一个有趣又好玩的爱好，就像吃蜂蜜和谈论医学一样。所以他和伊莎贝尔同居了。现在，与此同时，内莉怎么样了？1956年1月，显然一直没有收到庇隆的消息，
name, she had named herself after the wife. And the wife was called Isabel. So this is Isabel. Isabel is massively into spiritualism. When she meets Peron after doing her dancing, she's reading a book about Buddhism. And he just thinks, ah, this is an interesting and amusing hobby, like eating honey and talking about medicine. So he shacks up with Isabel. Now, meanwhile, what's happened to Nellie? In January 1956, having clearly not heard from Perron,
内莉决定去寻找他。据报道，警察在与巴拉圭的边境截获了她。她随身带着一台相机、一些珠宝、一些现金和这些贵宾犬。难怪她带着这么多贵宾犬很难过境。当局把她押回布宜诺斯艾利斯，并将她关进了一所少管所。她后来的生活还算顺利。据我所知，她嫁给了一位美国大使馆的工作人员。所以内莉，我的意思是，她是否因为与庇隆这段交往而受到创伤，我不得而知。这很不理想。但这就是她在这个故事中的结局。现在当然还有庇隆的另一个女人，我们在中场休息前应该提到她，那就是埃维塔。埃维塔一直躺在工会大楼三楼那个该死的实验室里。当政变发生、庇隆被赶下台时，所有的军方人员都上到实验室去寻找她的遗体。其中有一个人叫弗朗西斯科·曼里克的家伙。所以他留下了为数不多的极佳描述之一。他说，它的大小和一个12岁的女孩一样。它的皮肤像人造革一样打过蜡。它的嘴唇涂过胭脂，当你敲击它时，它发出像商店橱窗人体模型般空洞的声音。防腐师阿拉医生在它周围徘徊，仿佛那是他挚爱之物。
decides she's going to try to find him. The police picked her up, apparently, on the border with Paraguay. She had with her a camera, some jewelry, some cash, and these poodles. So no wonder she found it difficult to get across the border with all the poodles. The authorities brought her back to Buenos Aires, and they put her in a reform school. Life worked out well for her. She married somebody from the U.S. Embassy, I believe. So Nelly, I mean, whether she was
现在，军方迫切想要证明这是一具假尸体，因为正如你所说的，汤姆，他们想要从阿根廷历史上抹去庇隆夫妇的痕迹。所以他们实际上切断了她的一根手指并为其拍了X光片。结果发现它是真的，这让他们感到非常失望。我的意思是，这确实表明它带有一种真实的虚假品质，不是吗？他们多么希望它实际上是用塑料做的。是的。但它确实覆有一层塑料。我的意思是，整件事太诡异了。就像《尖叫狂欢》（Carry On Screaming）的结局一样。你还记得他们怎么变成人体模型的吗？或者就像《神秘博士》里那些有奥顿人（Autons）的剧集一样。总之，对这具遗体到底该怎么办呢？
traumatized by this association with Perón, I don't know. It's very sub-ideal. But that's the end of her in this story. Now there is, of course, another of Perón's women, which we should before we get to the break, which is Evita. Evita has been in this flipping laboratory on the third floor of the union building. When the coup happens and Poron is kicked out, all the army people go up to the laboratory to find her body. Now, one of them is a guy called Francisco Manrique. So he gives us one of the few very good descriptions. He says, it was the size of a 12-year-old girl. Its skin was waxed like an artificial. Its mouth had been rouged. And when you tapped it, it rang hollow like a store window mannequin. The embalmer, Dr. Ara, hovered over it as though it was something that he loved.
他们开了一会又开会，最终决定……好吧，我对此有个问题。他们为什么不直接把它烧了？他们是虔诚的天主教徒。所以他们对于使用电牛棒和电击诗人完全心安理得？不，这不是肮脏战争时期。所以他们此时并没有处决任何人或做类似的事？他们没有做任何那种事。我的意思是，我可不想惹上他们，但同样地，电牛棒在阿根廷政治文化中还没有后来那么突出。我的意思是，基本上他们面临的决定是该对遗体做些什么。这正是马丁内斯的小说开始变得相当巴洛克式的地方。不可能比实际发生的事情更巴洛克了。好吧。你能告诉我们接下来会发生什么吗，如果还有更多巴洛克式的细节，我会告诉你。所以他们最终决定将其转移，并将其秘密埋葬在布宜诺斯艾利斯的大型公墓查卡里塔（Chacarita）。
Now, the army are desperate to prove that it's a fake because, as you said, Tom, they want to erase the Perons from Argentine history. So they actually cut off one of her fingers and did an X-ray on it. And they were very disappointed to find out it was real. I mean, that does suggest that it's kind of got a real quality of fakeness, doesn't it? They want to think that it's actually made of plastic. Yeah. But it's covered with this layer of plastic. I mean, the whole thing is so weird. It's like the end of Carry On Screaming. Do you remember where they get turned into mannequins? Or like one of those Doctor Who episodes with the Autons. Anyway, what on earth to do with this body?
军事情报局局长——一个名叫毛里·科尼格（Maury Koenig）的男子——于1955年11月24日午夜来到了那里。他们举行了一场诡异的秘密转移仪式。运送它的那些人、清洁工们，据说由于情绪激动和恐惧而脸色苍白、大汗淋漓。它几乎就像是阿根廷的一个圣物。所以，拥有它某种程度上就能赋予你一种超自然的权力。正是如此。为什么他们会用如此做作夸张的方式来看待它？嗯，我想一切都是由此发展而来的，对吧？
They meet again and again, and they eventually decide... Well, I've got a question about this. Why don't they just burn it? They're good Catholics. So they're perfectly happy about using cattle prods and electrocuting poets? No, this isn't the dirty war territory. So they're not executing people or anything at this point? They're not doing any of that stuff. I mean, I wouldn't want to get on the wrong side of them, but equally, the cattle prod is not as prominent in Argentine political culture as it would later
所有那些集会，还有她死时的那些疯狂事件。所以现在这是一个非常诡异的故事。棺盖本该被焊接密封的。但焊工根本没有出现来合上棺盖。所以这是一个小问题，遗体现在是敞开着的。是的，是敞开的。阿拉医生已经被打发走了。他们对阿拉医生一直在周围晃荡、看起来极其阴险感到厌烦。他非常伤心，因为他们受够了他而被赶走了。所以科尼格事后说，他们把遗体运走了，却诡异地把它放在一辆卡车的后车厢里，因为它没有被焊接密封，他们开着车在城市里到处兜风，并停在
become. I mean, basically, the decision they've got as prominent in Argentine political culture as it would later become. I mean, basically the decision they've what to do with the body. This is where the Martinez novel really starts getting quite Baroque. Can't get more Baroque than what actually happened. Okay. Will you tell us what will happen and I'll tell you if there are further Baroque details. So eventually they decided they would move it and they would bury it secretly in the big cemetery in Buenos Aires called the Chacarita.
某种废弃的停车场里。但每天早晨当他们出现准备转移它时，都会神秘地发现卡车旁放着鲜花和一支蜡烛。这显然对科尼格的心理造成了巨大冲击——他是军事情报局的局长，但这极大程度地摧毁了他的心智。这是因为他在想，要么是安全部门里有叛徒，要么这就是某种超自然的显现。所以他做了一件我认为极其疯狂的事。他说，让我们放弃把它秘密埋葬在公墓的计划吧。
And the head of military intelligence, who was a man called Mr. Maury Koenig, went up there at midnight on the 24th of November, 1955. They have this bizarre ceremony where they carry it out in secret. The people carrying it, the cleaners carrying it, they're supposedly pale and sweating with emotion and terror. It's almost like she's an icon of Argentina. So to own her somehow gives you a supernatural quality of power. Exactly. Why do they think about it in such a histrionic way? Well, I suppose everything's been leading up to this, right?
军事情报局长莫里·科尼格先生于1955年11月24日午夜前往那里。他们举行了一场离奇的仪式，秘密将其运出。搬运的人、清洁工们据说都因激动和恐惧而脸色苍白、大汗淋漓。她几乎成了阿根廷的圣像。因此，拥有她某种程度上能赋予你一种超自然的权力。确实如此。为什么他们会用如此戏剧化的方式来看待这件事？嗯，我想这一切都是为了这一刻做铺垫，对吧？
All those rallies, all the mad stuff with when she died. So it's a very weird story now. The lid was meant to be welded shut. The welders never turn up to close the lid. So that's a very weird story now the lid was meant to be welded shut the welders never turn up to close the lid so that's a slight issue so the body is now open yeah it's open dr ara has been sent away they're like sick of dr hanging around looking incredibly sinister he's very sad he's been sent away because they're sick of him so koenig he says afterwards they took the body away and they left it bizarre in the back of a truck because it hadn't been welded shut and they kept driving it around the city and parking
所有的集会，还有她去世时那些疯狂的举动。所以现在这是一个非常诡异的故事。棺盖本该被焊死。但电焊工根本没有出现来合上棺盖。所以这是一个非常诡异的故事，棺盖本该被焊死，电焊工却没来合上，所以这就成了个小问题，遗体现在还是开棺的，是的，是开着的。阿劳医生被支走了，因为他们厌烦了阿劳医生总在那儿转悠、神情极其诡异。他非常伤心，被支走了，因为他们烦透了他。所以科尼格事后说，他们把遗体运走，由于没有焊死，竟然离奇地把它放在卡车后面，他们开着卡车在城里到处转，然后停放
in sort of disused car parks but every morning when they turn up to move it they would find mysteriously flowers and a single candle by the side of the truck this obviously plays with koenig's he's the head of their military intelligence, but this massively plays with his mind. And it's because he's thinking either there are traitors in the security services or it is some supernatural manifestation. So he does what I think is a mad thing to do. He says, let's abandon the plan to bury it secret in a cemetery.
在一些废弃的停车场里。但每天早上当他们去移车时，都会神秘地发现卡车旁边摆着鲜花和一支蜡烛。这显然对科尼格的心理造成了极大冲击——他是军事情报局长，但这彻底击垮了他的心理防线。因为他觉得，要么是安全部门有叛徒，要么就是某种超自然现象。于是他做了一件我认为非常疯狂的事。他说，放弃把遗体秘密埋葬在墓地的计划。
I'll put it... In a filing cabinet. Well, actually, I believe he puts it in the cemetery. I'll put it in a filing cabinet. Well, actually, I believe he puts it in the attic above his storage space, above his office in the military. Imagine this plastic looking body of Evita has now been shoved into this space, literally above the desk at which he is working. So in the Martinez novel, there are two refinements to this. It's briefly stored in the office of an officer who Koenig thinks has gone away. And the officer comes back early and walks into the office. What the hell is that? But then it gets even creepier because this must be made up. I can't believe that this is true. There's a major Arantibia
我把它放进……一个档案柜里。嗯，实际上，我相信他是把它放在他储藏室上面的阁楼里，在军队里他的办公室上面。想象一下，艾薇塔这个看起来像塑料的尸体现在被塞进了这个空间， literalmente 就在他办公桌的正上方。所以在那部马丁内斯的虚构小说中，对此有两个更具体的细节。它被短暂地存放在一个军官的办公室里，库尼格认为这个军官已经离开了。然后那个军官提前回来，走进了办公室。那到底是什么鬼？但接下来事情变得更加诡异，因为这肯定是编出来的。我简直不敢相信这是真的。有一个叫阿兰蒂维亚的高级将领
who gets given the body to look after, and he falls in love with it and has a kind of necrophiliac relations with it, gets discovered by his pregnant wife, who he then shoots and claims that he had mistaken his wife for a burglar. I've never heard that version. So the version I'd heard was that Koenig, the head of military intelligence, eventually told somebody he was sweating, looking furtive all this time, like he was a haunted man. And eventually he told somebody I've got Evita's body hidden in my office. They told the president he was sacked at this point. Koenig's gone mad.
有人把尸体交给他照看，结果他爱上了尸体，并和它发生了类似恋尸癖的关系，结果被他怀孕的妻子发现了，于是他开枪打死了妻子，并声称他把妻子错当成了入室盗窃的小偷。我从来没听过那个版本。所以我听说的版本是，军事情报部门负责人库尼格最终告诉了某人，他一直在流汗，神色鬼祟，就像一个被鬼魂纠缠的人。最后他告诉某人，我把艾薇塔的尸体藏在我的办公室里。他们把这事告诉了总统，这时候他被解雇了。库尼格疯了。
Yeah, you've gone mad. And the president, who's now called Aramburu, there's been a lot of churn in the regime. He says, look, we've got to sort this thing out. And he basically contacts the Vatican or contacts the Catholic hierarchy and they do a deal. And this is genuinely what happened. This mysterious Italian priest arrived in Buenos Aires and he collected the coffin, which they'd prepared. He gave President Aramburu a sealed envelope with details of where the body is going. Aramburu gave this envelope to his lawyer and he said, a month after my death, give this to my successor as president of Argentina. He can open it. He can do what he likes, but then I will be gone and I'll be rid of this.
对，你疯了。而那位现在叫阿拉姆布鲁的总统——政权经历了很多动荡。他说，听着，我们必须把这事解决掉。他基本上联系了梵蒂冈，或者联系了天主教高层，然后他们达成了一笔交易。这真的是真实发生的。这个神秘的意大利神父抵达了布宜诺斯艾利斯，他取走了他们准备好的棺材。他给阿拉姆布鲁总统递了一个密封的信封，里面详细说明了尸体要去哪里。阿拉姆布鲁把这个信封交给了他的律师，并说，在我死后一个月，把这个交给我作为阿根廷总统的继任者。他可以打开它。他可以做他想做的事，但到那时我就已经不在了，我也就甩掉这个大包袱了。
And with that, Evita vanishes. The body vanished. It wasn't mentioned. No one knew where it had gone. The Italian priest has disappeared with it and no one knows what has happened. But the envelope is still in situ in the Argentine president's office. And of course, this is not the end of the story. And Tom, after the break, we will discover what happened to Peron?
随之，艾薇塔消失了。尸体消失了。无人提及。没有人知道它去了哪里。那个意大利神父和它一起消失了，没有人知道发生了什么。但那个信封仍然原封不动地放在阿根廷总统的办公室里。当然，这并不是故事的结束。托姆，中场休息后，我们将揭晓庇隆身上发生了什么？
What happened to that occult crazed dancer that he was now involved with? And what happened above all to Evita's body? Come back after the break for the mad climax of this extraordinary story. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
那个他现在卷入其中的、崇拜神秘主义的疯狂舞者身上发生了什么？最重要的是，艾薇塔的尸体发生了什么？中场休息后回来，收看这个非凡故事的疯狂高潮。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History, the final section of our five-part epic on the life of Evita. Dominic, Evita has vanished. Peron is in exile. Before we come to them, what condition is Argentina in by now? Let's fast forward 10 years, 15 years or so, to the middle of the end of the 1960s. Argentina is
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史之巅》，这是我们关于艾薇塔一生的五集史诗的最后一部分。多米尼克，艾薇塔已经消失了。庇隆流亡在外。在我们谈到他们之前，阿根廷现在是什么状况？让我们快进10年，15年左右，来到20世纪60年代中后期。阿根廷陷入了
in a greater mess than ever before. Economic, terrible woes, high inflation, labor unrest. The army have never been able to set up a workable regime that lasts. And there is now a real romance, a retrospective romance of Peron, of Peronism and particularly of Evita. And we mentioned last time how at the end of her life, when she was on a lot of drugs and in a huge amount of pain, her speeches had become increasingly violent and confrontational. And this is the Evita that is picked up in the late 1960s by students, by radicals, by this sort of newly emboldened left of Argentine politics, influenced by Castro and the Cuban
比以往任何时候都更严重的混乱。经济状况极其糟糕，高通胀，劳工动荡。军队从来没能建立一个持久且行之有效的政权。现在人们对庇隆、庇隆主义特别是艾薇塔产生了一种真正的浪漫情怀，一种对过去的浪漫想象。我们上次提到，在她生命的尽头，当她服用了大量药物且承受巨大痛苦时，她的演讲变得越来越暴力和充满对抗性。而这就是20世纪60年代末被学生、激进分子、阿根廷政治中这种新近受到鼓舞的左翼所接受的艾薇塔的形象，他们受到了卡斯特罗和古巴革命的影响。
Revolution. But also the kind of the Soissons-Vita in Paris and Berkeley and all that. All of that, exactly. They take up Evita as their icon. So in 1969, there was an uprising in the city of Cordoba, ironically the place where the coup against Perón had begun. There was street fighting between students and the police. The government cracks down and declares a state of siege.
但也受到巴黎、伯克利等地的苏瓦松-维塔（Soissons-Vita）的影响。完全就是那些。他们把艾薇塔奉为偶像。所以在1969年，科尔多瓦市爆发了一场起义，具有讽刺意味的是，正是那个反对庇隆的政变开始的地方。学生和警察之间爆发了街头冲突。政府进行镇压并宣布进入戒严状态。
And that really is the cue for Argentina to descend into a kind of anarchy of competing radical guerrilla terrorist groups. The most famous ones are called the Montoneros. But there's also, I mean, it's real People's Front of Judea stuff, Tom. There's the Peronist Armed Forces, the Revolutionary Armed Forces, the Armed Forces of Liberation, and the People's Revolutionary Army. You don't want to get them mixed up because they'll kill you. You might get shot. Exactly.
这确实成了阿根廷陷入各种相互竞争的激进游击恐怖主义组织无政府状态的导火索。最著名的组织被称为蒙托内罗斯（Montoneros）。但也有——我的意思是，这简直是犹太人民阵线的翻版，托姆。有庇隆主义武装力量、革命武装力量、解放武装力量以及人民革命军。你可不想把它们搞混，因为它们会杀了你。你可能会被枪杀。没错。
The estimates are that there were about 40,000 terrorists and guerrillas in Argentina at the beginning of the 1970s. And these are university educated. So they're kind of posh terrorists. Badermeyerhoff type. Very Badermeyerhoff. We did an episode about the Tupamaros in Uruguay who are exactly the same, basically. And Evita is their touchstone. She is their inspiration.
据估计，20世纪70年代初阿根廷大约有4,000名恐怖分子和游击队员。这些人都是受过大学教育的。所以他们算是那种高雅的恐怖分子。巴德尔-迈因霍夫（Baader-Meinhof）类型。非常像巴德尔-迈因霍夫。我们做过一期关于乌拉圭图帕马罗斯（Tupamaros）的节目，他们基本上完全一样。而艾薇塔就是他们的精神支柱。她是他们的灵感来源。
So you will see graffiti in Buenos Aires in 1970, 71. Evita viva. Evita lives. And at rallies, they will have open rallies and they will chant, se siente, se siente, Evita está presente. We can feel it. We can feel it. Evita is here.
所以你会看到1970年、1971年在布宜诺斯艾利斯到处都是涂鸦。Evita viva。艾薇塔万岁。艾薇塔永存。在集会上，他们会举行公开集会并高呼：se siente, se siente, Evita está presente。我们能感受到。我们能感受到。艾薇塔就在这里。
This is one of their great hymns. Are they agitated by the fact her body's vanished? Do they have any interest in that? Or is that not really what they're into? People do say, where is she? What has happened to her? I mean, the Peronist movement is very angry about this. That she's vanished.
这是他们伟大的赞歌之一。他们对她的尸体失踪这件事感到焦虑吗？他们对此有什么兴趣吗？还是说这根本不是他们关心的重点？人们确实在问：她在哪里？她发生了什么事？我的意思是，庇隆主义运动对此非常愤怒。因为她消失了。
That she's vanished. They've never got their memorial. They don't even have a gravestone. So it is inflammatory that she's disappeared. I can see that they would be into Evita because she's safely dead. But what about Peron? Because Peron must be about 170 by now. No, Peron is only 70, Tom. Very harsh. Okay. That's still quite old though, if you're a radical student in the late 60s. By the standards of the politics of the United States, he's a spring chicken. Yes, exactly. So Peron has since moved to Madrid. He's got married to that
因为她消失了。他们从来没有得到他们的纪念碑。他们甚至连一块墓碑都没有。所以她的失踪具有煽动性。我能理解他们为什么会迷恋艾薇塔，因为她已经安稳地死去了。那庇隆呢？因为庇隆现在大概有170岁了吧？不，庇隆只有70岁，托姆。太苛刻了。好吧。不过如果你是60年代末的激进学生，这依然算挺老了。以美国政客的标准来看，他正值壮年。是的，没错。所以庇隆此后搬到了马德里。他娶了那个
dancer, Isabel. He was never massively into Isabel. It's generally thought that he got married really to please Franco because General Franco said, you know, I'm all about kind of the family, the Catholic church, establishment values. I can't have you hanging around Madrid with this dancer. You need to marry her and make an honest woman of her. And Perron, you know, he still is kind of slightly easygoing, says, yeah, well, whatever. He started to use Isabel. She's not political at all. She likes her honey, spiritualism.
舞者伊莎贝尔。他从来没有真正迷恋过伊莎贝尔。人们普遍认为他结婚主要是为了取悦弗朗哥，因为弗朗哥将军曾说，你知道的，我非常看重家庭、天主教教会以及建制派价值观。我不能容忍你带着这个舞者在马德里晃荡。你需要娶她，让她成为一个正派女人。而庇隆呢，你知道的，他依然有点随遇而安，就说，好吧，随便吧。他开始利用伊莎贝尔。她一点也不关心政治。她喜欢她的蜂蜜、精神灵修。
Talking about medicine. Exactly, talking about medicine. She can travel back to Argentina. She's from Argentina. She's from the city of La Rioja in Argentina. And he says, you can go back and talk to underground Peronist groups and whatnot for me. She will go back and she'll turn up in Buenos Aires. She knows nothing about politics.
谈论医学。没错，谈论医学。她可以回到阿根廷。她来自阿根廷。她来自阿根廷的拉里奥哈市。他说，你可以回去，替我跟底层的庇隆主义组织等等进行交流。她会回去，然后出现在布宜诺斯艾利斯。她对政治一无所知。
And all these Peronist youth groups will kind of gather outside her hotel and say, we'll be your bodyguards. Let us carry your bags. And she's not talking to the government, to anti-Peronist forces at this point? No, not really. But she will travel around the country. There's stories of her during a political campaign in Mendoza in the West. She'll be traveling around and people will come to the side of the road.
所有这些庇隆主义青年组织都会聚集在她的酒店外面说，我们来当你的保镖吧。让我们帮你拿行李。她当时没有跟政府或反庇隆主义势力对话吗？不，并没有。但她会全国各地到处跑。有故事说，在西部门多萨的一次政治竞选期间。她四处奔波，人们会来到路边。
They will try to lay hands on her as if she's a saint. As if she's Evita, presumably. This is precisely the point. That she is basically already at this point being cast as Evita. The real Evita, the waxwork, has vanished. So Peron is creating his own, which is Isabel. Well, you can see why. I mean, she's young, she's married to Peron, and she's from a theatrical background.
他们试图伸手触摸她，仿佛她是一位圣人。大概就像她是艾薇塔一样。这正是关键所在。她基本上在那个时候就已经被塑造成了艾薇塔。真正的艾薇塔，那个蜡像，已经消失了。所以庇隆正在创造他自己的艾薇塔，那就是伊莎贝尔。好吧，你可以理解原因。我的意思是，她很年轻，嫁给了庇隆，而且她出身于戏剧界。
Yes, exactly. So now, among the people who attach themselves to Isabel, the new Evita, is a very peculiar man. He is a guy who had once been in the police and seems to have worked as a security man for Peron at some point. His name is Jose Lopez Rega. And this guy, he follows Isabel back to Madrid, basically carrying her bags. And somehow he gets a post in the kind of Peron ménage in Madrid as a handyman at the house initially.
是的，完全如此。所以现在，在那些依附于伊莎贝尔——这个新艾薇塔——的人当中，有一个非常奇特的人。他是一个曾经当过警察的人，似乎在某个时候曾担任庇隆的安保人员。他的名字叫何塞·洛佩斯·雷加（Jose Lopez Rega）。这个人跟着伊莎贝尔回到了马德里，基本上帮她拎行李。不知何故，他在马德里的庇隆宅邸里谋得了一个职位，最初是作为家里的杂工。
Now, Jose Lopez Rega is obsessed with the occult. That's probably why he and Isabel bonded. He, as a young policeman, had got really interested in a Brazilian cult called Candomblé, which is a sort of syncretic religion that had flourished among slaves in Brazil. A kind of South American voodoo. Yeah. And he wrote books about spiritualism. His masterwork, Tom, was called Esoteric Astrology, Secrets Revealed. And it was dictated to him by the angel Gabriel while he was asleep. Oh, so he's like Muhammad. Well, the difference, Tom, is that I have no criticisms to make of Muhammad, obviously, but Lopez Rega, as it will turn out, is quite a different kettle
现在，何塞·洛佩斯·雷加痴迷于神秘主义。这可能就是他和伊莎贝尔建立联系的原因。他作为一个年轻警察时，对一个名为康东布莱（Candomblé）的巴西邪教产生了浓厚的兴趣，这是一种在巴西奴隶中繁荣起来的融合宗教。一种南美洲的巫毒教。对。他还写过关于灵修的书。托姆，他的代表作叫《秘传占星术：揭秘》。这是他在睡梦中由天使加百列口述给他的。哦，所以他就像穆罕默德一样。嗯，不同之处在于，托姆，我对穆罕默德没有任何批评，显然，但事实证明，洛佩斯·雷加完全是另外一回事。
of fish. We'll just put that on the record. We are not comparing this guy to the Prophet Muhammad. Peron's hangers-on initially treat this guy, Lopez Rega, as a joke. They call him El Brujo, the warlock, and it catches on. After a while, Peron discovers that the warlock is selling a drug in Brazil that can rejuvenate you. And Lopez Rega is selling this drug with Peron's face on it. Rejuvenate you kind of like Viagra or literally? Literally rejuvenate you.
我们把这话记在录音里。我们可不是在拿这个人跟先知穆罕默德作比较。庇隆的随从们最初把这个叫洛佩斯·雷加的人当成一个笑话。他们叫他“埃尔布鲁霍”（El Brujo），即巫师，这个外号很快流传开来。过了一段时间，庇隆发现这个巫师在巴西售卖一种可以让人返老还童的药物。而且洛佩斯·雷加售卖的这种药上面还印着庇隆的脸。返老还童，有点像伟哥还是字面意义上的？字面意义上的返老还童。
So kind of like a vampire drinking blood. The claim that Lopez Rega makes is he says, Peron only stays young. I mean, actually, Peron is like pouring industrial quantities of dye into his hair and stuff in traditional exiled Latin American dictator style. But the warlock says the drug is keeping him young. Peron discovers this and tries to kick the warlock out of his house. But then Peron falls ill. He has tumors in his urethra, very unpleasant, and he needs care. And actually, López Rega returns to the house and he and Isabel become, they basically end up controlling Peron. So they become indispensable to him.
所以有点像吸血鬼喝血。洛佩斯·雷加声称的是，他说，只有庇隆能保持年轻。我的意思是，实际上，庇隆就像传统的流亡拉丁美洲独裁者风格一样，往头发里倾倒工业级别的染发剂之类。但巫师说这种药让他保持年轻。庇隆发现了这一点，并试图把巫师赶出他的家。但接着庇隆生病了。他的尿道长了肿瘤，非常痛苦，需要人照顾。事实上，洛佩斯·雷加回到了房子里，他和伊莎贝尔最终控制了庇隆。所以他们对他变得不可或缺。
So this, Tom, is the situation when in 1971, the new Argentine president, they've had a multitude of presidents. They've got a guy called Alejandro Agustin Lanús, who is the new military president. And he says, look, we're never going to get out of this mess unless we basically reincorporate the Peronists back into Argentine politics. And the first thing I'll do is I will relax all those laws that had erased them, that had erased mentions of Evita. So now at the beginning of the 70s, the cult of Evita comes back kind of above ground. V.S. Naipaul, the great writer, went to Argentina in 1972 and he said, her pictures everywhere, touched up, seldom sharp,
所以，托姆，这就是当时的局势：1971年，阿根廷的新总统——他们经历过无数位总统。他们有一位名叫亚历杭德罗·奥古斯丁·拉努斯（Alejandro Agustin Lanus）的人，他是新的军事总统。他说，听着，除非我们基本上把庇隆主义者重新纳回阿根廷政治，否则我们永远无法摆脱这个烂摊子。我要做的第一件事，就是放松所有那些曾试图抹去他们、抹去对艾薇塔提及的法律。所以在70年代初，艾薇塔的崇拜以某种方式重新浮出水面。伟大的作家V.S.奈保尔（V.S. Naipaul）在1972年去了阿根廷，他说，到处都是她的画像，经过修饰，很少清晰，
and often they seem like religious pictures made for the very poor. A young woman with great beauty, with blonde hair, a very white skin, and the very red lips of the 1940s. There's a cult of, a massive cult of Evita at the beginning of the 70s when Argentina is in this terrible economic and political mess. And this, of course, is the backdrop to the making of the musical. Yes. Now, General Lanus thinks, I want to win over the Peronists.
而且它们通常看起来像是为穷人制作的宗教画。一个非常美丽的年轻女性，金发，白皙的皮肤，以及1940年代那种非常红的嘴唇。在70年代初阿根廷陷入这种可怕的经济和政治混乱时，对艾薇塔的崇拜达到了狂热的程度。而这，当然就是这部音乐剧创作的背景。是的。现在，拉努斯将军心想，我想赢得庇隆主义者的支持。
The best way to do that, given the cult that is flourishing, is to track down the body. And so he does that one thing that his predecessors had not done. He opens the envelope. I can't believe that no one had opened the envelope. I mean, it's kind of like saying, don't think of an elephant, isn't it? Don't open the envelope. I can't believe that no one had opened the envelope. I mean, it's kind of like saying, don't think of an elephant, isn't it? Don't open the envelope. I would become president of Argentina just so that I could open that envelope. I don't see you as president of Argentina material, to be quite honest with you, Tom. No, but it's kind of like the one reason that
鉴于这种蓬勃发展的崇拜，实现这一目标的最佳方法就是追踪尸体。于是他做了一件他的前任们没有做过的事。他打开了信封。我简直不敢相信竟然没有人打开过信封。我的意思是，这有点像“不要去想一头大象”，对吧？不要打开信封。我简直不敢相信竟然没有人打开过信封。我的意思是，这有点像“不要去想一头大象”，对吧？不要打开信封。我会为了能够打开那个信封而去竞选阿根廷总统。老实说，托姆，我觉得你一点也不具备当阿根廷总统的材料。不，但这就好像
I'd want to become president of the United States is so that I could, you know, tell me what happened at Roswell. I'd want to know this. If I'm picturing you in art and time politics at the beginning of the seventies, I see you in the back of a boot being driven off to a helicopter. No, I think you're a big fan of Graham Green, like our producer, Tony Pastor. No, not really. In his novel, The Honorary Consul, somebody has taken hostage by mistake. Oh, so that would be me. That's got you all over it. Right. So he opens the envelope and it has in it, I mean, it's like such damn brown material, the name of a priest and the address of a cemetery in Milan. So the president sends an army intelligence colonel to Milan and he finds out that the priest has died in the interim. But
我想成为美国总统的唯一原因就是为了能——你知道的，告诉我罗斯韦尔事件到底发生了什么。我想知道这个。如果我脑补你在七十年代初的阿根廷政治中，我能想象你藏在汽车后备箱里被拉去直升机那里。不，我觉得你就像我们的制作人托尼·帕斯特（Tony Pastor）一样，是格雷厄姆·格林（Graham Green）的超级粉丝。不，并不是。在他的小说《名誉领事》（The Honorary Consul）中，有人阴差阳错被绑架了。哦，那不就是我吗。这完全就是你的风格。好吧。于是他打开了信封，里面写着——我的意思是，这太像格雷厄姆·格林小说的素材了——一个神父的名字和米兰一个公墓的地址。所以总统派了一名军事情报上校去米兰，他发现那位神父在此期间已经去世了。但是
he goes to the cemetery. He looks through, Is there anyone here from any Argentine connections? Yes. In 1956, there is a widow called Maria Maggi de Magistris, who was supposedly born in Italy, went to Argentina, was widowed, and then was brought back to Milan to be buried. The colonel grows a moustache, impersonates this woman's brother, and somehow gets a permit from the Italian authorities to exhume the body. He says he lives in Spain now and to take it back with him to Spain. So on the 2nd of September, 1971, this group of very sunglass wearing,
他去了公墓。他查阅记录：“这里有任何与阿根廷有关联的人吗？”有的。1956年，有一位名叫玛丽亚·马吉·德·马吉斯特里斯（Maria Maggi de Magistris）的寡妇，据说出生在意大利，去过阿根廷，守寡后被带回米兰安葬。这位上校留起了胡子，假扮成这个女人的兄弟，不知何故从意大利当局那里弄到了挖掘尸体的许可。他说他现在住在西班牙，要把尸体带回西班牙。因此，在1971年9月2日，这群戴着墨镜、
slightly sinister looking men dig up this body in Milan. They put it in the back of a van. They drive it through Italy, through France, into Spain. When they get to Spain, they transfer it to another van, an unmarked van. So they're not being stopped on the way by customs officials. Who knows what's happened. So they arrive finally in the Madrid suburb of Puerto de Hierro, which is the house of Juan Perón. And there waiting for them are Perón, Isabel, the warlock,
看起来有点阴险的男人在米兰挖出了这具尸体。他们把它放进一辆货车的后备箱。他们驾车穿过意大利、法国，进入西班牙。当他们到达西班牙时，他们把它转移到另一辆货车上，一辆没有标记的货车。这样他们在路上就不会被海关官员拦下。谁知道会发生什么。所以他们最终抵达了马德里郊区的韦尔塔德伊耶罗（Puerto de Hierro），那是胡安·庇隆的住所。而在那里等待他们的是庇隆、伊莎贝尔、巫师，
and Dr. Ara, the embalmer. Oh my God, he's come back. They open the coffin and they're hit by a sweet smell, apparently. And Peron just says, motionlessly, he just says, it's Evita. Now, Dr. Ara says the hair was wet. They unpinned the hair. Isabel starts to kind of smooth the hair and smooth off bits of dirt and rust. Now, they look more closely. The nose has been flattened. It's obviously been hit by the lid at some point.
以及防腐师阿拉医生（Dr. Ara）。天哪，他又回来了。他们打开棺材，显然扑面而来的是一股甜美的气味。庇隆只是静静地说，他只是说：“是艾薇塔。”现在，阿拉医生说头发还是湿的。他们解开头发。伊莎贝尔开始帮她理顺头发，并拂去残存的污垢和铁锈。现在，他们仔细观察。鼻子被压扁了。显然在某个时候被棺材盖撞击过。
So that's quite like Alexander's nose being knocked off, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. But there is no doubt this is Ava. So what then happens is Isabel takes the body out, washes it and does its hair. I find that quite weird. You know, somebody doing the hair of her predecessor who's been dead for 20 years.
所以这有点像亚历山大大帝的鼻子被撞掉了一样，对吧？对。对。但毫无疑问，这就是艾薇塔。所以接下来发生的事情是，伊莎贝尔把尸体取出来，给她洗澡并做发型。我觉得这挺诡异的。你知道的，一个人去给死去了20年的前任做发型。
Anyway, Isabel does this. Evita's family want it to be buried, of course. They say, for God's sake, give her a decent burial. But Perron says, no, the body is too useful. family want it to be buried of course they say for god's sake give her a decent burial but perron says no the body is too useful it's like ptolemy taking alexander's body back to alexandria totally so what he does which i find absolutely unfathomable is he says just put the body in an upstairs bedroom that's what they do but it doesn't end there because you've got the warlock on the scene never madness to have a man called the
不管怎样，伊莎贝尔这样做了。艾薇塔的家人当然希望她能入土为安。他们说，看在上帝的份上，给她一个体面的葬礼吧。但庇隆说，不，这具尸体太有用了。家人当然希望她能入土为安，他们说，看在上帝的份上，给她一个体面的葬礼吧。但庇隆说，不，这具尸体太有用了。这就像托勒密把亚历山大的尸体带回亚历山大港一样。完全如此。所以他做了什么呢——我觉得这完全不可理喻——他说，就把尸体放在楼上的卧室里。他们就是这么做的。但事情并没有结束，因为现场还有那个巫师。让一个被称为巫师的男人住在你家里，身边还放着一具保存完好的尸体，这绝对是在自找麻烦。庇隆府邸里渐渐传出流言，你绝对猜不到楼上的房间里发生了什么：在庇隆就寝后的夜晚，巫师会和伊莎贝尔一起上楼。他让伊莎贝尔躺在棺材上面，我猜盖着盖子吧，我猜是的。与此同时，他点燃蜡烛，焚烧香料，并喃喃念着咒语。其目的基本上是唤醒艾薇塔的灵魂和某种精神本质，并以某种方式将其融入伊莎贝尔的脑海中。好让她变成艾薇塔。现在你可能会说这绝对太离谱了。庇隆的学术传记作家约瑟夫·佩奇（Joseph Page）说：太荒谬了，但完全可信。
warlock living in your house with a perfectly preserved body asking for trouble word leaks out of the peril menage that the you'll never guess what's going on in the upstairs room that at night while peron has retired the warlock goes up there with isabel. He gets Isabel to lie on top of the coffin, I'm presuming with the lid on, I would assume. Meanwhile, he lights candles and burns incense and he mutters incantations. And the point is to basically revive Evita's soul and sort of spiritual essence and somehow integrate it into the mind of Isabel. So that she becomes Evita. And now you may say this is absolutely bizarre. Peron's academic biographer, Joseph Page, says, fantastic, but entirely credible.
所以你可以理解为什么这会吸引一位在南美魔幻现实主义小说传统中成长起来的小说家。这太不合情理了。但我没有理由怀疑它没有发生过。好吧，在阿根廷国内，局势已经彻底失控。到处都是爆炸、抢劫、绑架。1972年底，庇隆带着伊莎贝尔短暂回国。他们进行着这样的日常：一大群人会聚集在他们的窗外。
So you can see why this would appeal to a novelist raised in the magical realist tradition of South American fiction. It's so implausible. I've no reason to doubt that it happened. Well, in Argentina itself, the situation has gone completely out of control. There are bombings, there are robberies, there are kidnappings all the time. Perón comes briefly back at the end of 1972 with Isabel. They do this daily routine where a huge crowd will gather outside their window.
她会和他一起走出来，手里拿着一张巨大的艾薇塔照片，并带领人群高呼口号：“se siente, se siente, Evita está presente”。好吧，我的意思是，她字面意义上就是艾薇塔，不是吗？他们把尸体随身带回来了吗？没有，尸体还在马德里。但你可以说，如果那个咒语奏效了，伊莎贝尔体内承载着她，那么艾薇塔很可能就在现场。谁知道呢？
She will come out with him carrying a huge enlarged photograph of Evita and she will lead the crowd in the chants, se siente, se siente, Evita este presente. Well, I mean, she literally is, isn't she? Have they taken the body with them? No, the body is back in Madrid. But you could say Evita may well be present if that spell has worked and Isabel is carrying her within her. Who knows?
好吧。所以现在一切都在朝着庇隆的政治回归大步迈进。1973年春天，举行了一场总统选举。庇隆主义者终于被允许推出候选人，但候选人不能是庇隆本人。庇隆推举了他的一个傀儡，这个人叫坎帕拉（Campara），曾是一名牙医。坎帕拉当选总统，并任命谁担任他的社会福利部部长呢？追随埃娃·庇隆的脚步，
Right. So now everything is really moving forward towards Peron's political return. In the spring of 1973, there's a presidential election. The Peronists are at last allowed to put forward a candidate, but it's not allowed to be Peron himself. Peron puts forward a creature of his, this man called Mr. Campara, who's a former dentist. Campara becomes president and as his minister of social welfare, following in the footsteps of Eva Perón,
你觉得他任命了谁？伊莎贝尔。不，你看，我以为你会说伊莎贝尔。哦，那个巫师。他任命了巫师。这样他就可以利用他的巫术为阿根廷医疗卫生服务谋福利了。现在你觉得这全是一场滑稽可笑的闹剧。
who do you think he appoints? Isabel. No, you see, I thought you'd say Isabel. Oh, the warlock. He appoints the warlock. So he can use his necromantic powers for the benefit of the Argentine health service. Now you think this is all a great comedy and a mad comedy.
事实上，这带来了严重的后果。1973年6月，庇隆进行了他伟大的——他之前已经回来过一次，但现在他要进行他重返阿根廷的大型重头戏。他抵达了布宜诺斯艾利斯的埃塞萨国际机场（Ezeiza Airport）。据估计，机场有大约350万人在那里等候他。但到这个时候，阿根廷政治已经陷入如此疯狂的螺旋，以至于出现了相互敌对的右翼和左翼庇隆主义准军事组织。左翼组织高呼：“庇隆、艾薇塔，社会主义祖国”，
Actually, there are serious consequences. In June 1973, Perón makes his great, he's already come back once, but now he's going to make his big set piece return to Argentina. And he comes to Ezeiza Airport, the big international airport in Buenos Aires. There are, some estimates, three and a half million people waiting for him there at the airport. But by this point, Argentine politics has spiraled into such madness that there are rival right-wing and left-wing Peronist paramilitary groups. The left-wing ones are chanting, Peron Evita, the socialist fatherland,
而右翼组织则高呼：“庇隆、艾薇塔，庇隆主义祖国”。他们用这些口号相互抗衡。然后最终他们开始互相开枪射击。我的意思是，这确实显示了政治中“广纳贤才”方法的局限性，不是吗？以及歌唱比赛是如何轻而易举地演变成更具阴暗色彩的事情的。无论如何，左翼的人总是说：“你知道的，我们遭到了右翼狙击手的伏击。”右翼的人则说正好相反。这次事件中可能有数百人丧生。
and the right-wing ones are chanting, Peron Evita, the Peronist fatherland. And they're kind of competing with these chants. Then eventually they just start shooting at each other. I mean, that does show the limits of a big tent approach, doesn't it, in politics? And how song contests can quite easily spiral into something more sinister. Anyway, the people on the left always say, you know, we were ambushed by right-wing snipers. The right-wing people say the opposite. Probably hundreds of people were killed at this event.
庇隆的飞机实际上不得不改变航线，不幸的是，它降落在了一个名字叫“莫龙”（Moron）的地方。莫龙。莫龙机场空军基地。他降落时心脏病发作了。哦，天哪。所以他当时基本上已经快死了，但他还是参加了总统竞选。
And Peron's plane actually has to be rerouted, and it lands in, unfortunately, titled Moron. Moron. Moron Airport Air Base. He had a heart attack as they were landing. Oh, God. So he's basically dying at this point, but he runs for president anyway.
于是他们举行了另一场总统选举。所以他当时基本上已经死了。好吧，你会看到，托姆，他到底是死是活，或者他是否早已经死了，一会儿就会揭晓。现在，听过上一集的人都会记得，关于艾薇塔是否会成为他的副总统竞选搭档，曾引发过巨大的轩然大波。这一次，毫无疑问。伊莎贝尔是他的竞选搭档。
So they have another presidential election. So he's basically dead by this point. Well, you'll see, Tom, whether he's dead or not, or whether he's actually been dead already in a second. Now, people who listened to the last episode will remember the huge hullabaloo about whether Evita would be his vice presidential running mate. This time, there is no doubt whatsoever. Isabel is his running mate.
既然他已经一只脚踏进鬼门关，所有人都知道伊莎贝尔将成为阿根廷总统。这是一个令人难以置信的步骤，因为她没有任何从政经验，也不懂政治。我的意思是，鉴于她对医学的兴趣，她在卫生政策方面肯定相当熟练。庇隆以压倒性优势赢得大选，每个人都认为太棒了，苦日子结束了。顺便说一句，庇隆在1973年10月就职时，正值他78岁生日后第四天。这和乔·拜登就职时的年龄以及如果特朗普再次当选时的年龄一样。那巫师呢？
And since he's at death's door, everybody knows Isabel is going to be president of Argentina. This is an unbelievable step because she has no political experience, no knowledge of politics. I mean, she must be quite adept at health policy with her interest in medicine. Perón wins this massive landslide and everybody thinks, brilliant, the days of misery are over. By the way, Perón at this point, when he's inaugurated in October 1973, it's four days after his 78th birthday. That is the same age as Joe Biden when he was inaugurated and Trump if he wins again. And what about the warlock?
他过得怎么样？很多人认为巫师才是幕后的真正权臣。所以巫师何塞·洛佩斯·雷加，他依然是社会福利部部长。他把大部分时间花在为艾薇塔设计一个巨大的万神殿上，但他的行为也非常古怪。首先，他和庇隆以及伊莎贝尔住在总统府里。他在庇隆的床底安装了窃听设备，这样他就能监听庇隆，留意晚上的异常声音。他告诉庇隆宫廷里的其他人，他说：“听着，庇隆其实已经死了。庇隆死在马德里了，但我把他复活了。”
How is he getting on? A lot of people think the warlock is the real power behind the scenes here. So the warlock, López Rega, he's still the minister of social welfare. He spends most of his time designing a huge pantheon for evita but he's also behaving in very peculiar ways so first of all he lives with peron and isabel in the presidential palace he puts a listening device on peron's bed so that he can listen to peron and listen for unusual sounds at night. He tells other people in the sort of Peron court, he says, listen, Peron actually is dead. Peron died in Madrid, but I have revived him.
“只要我和庇隆在一起，他就不会死。”而且他某种程度上也把艾薇塔从死里复活了，不是吗？把她的生命力注入了伊莎贝尔体内。所以在某种意义上，他把艾薇塔和庇隆都从死里复活了，而他是他们的主人。但他说的前后矛盾，托姆，因为在其他时候，他声称庇隆其实是一位埃及法老。
And as long as I am with Peron, he cannot die. And also he's kind of raised Evita from the dead, hasn't he? And put her life force into Isabel. So in a sense, he's brought both Evita and Peron back from the dead, and he is their master. But he's telling inconsistent stories there, Tom, because at other times he claims that Peron is actually an Egyptian pharaoh.
当然。现在这个人掌握着巨额预算，不仅如此，他还把部分预算花在了右翼行刑队、反共行刑队上。所以现在全国到处都是互相敌对的庇隆主义行刑队，绑架人、枪杀人。所以巫师的那支叫作AAA。那敌对的那支叫什么？蒙托内罗斯（Montaneros）。也就是左翼庇隆主义的那支。所以政治现在
Of course. Now this guy is controlling a big budget, and what is more, he is spending some of his budget on right-wing death squads, on anti-communist death squads. So now there are rival Peronist death squads roaming around the country, kidnapping people, shooting people. So the Warlocks one is called the AAA. Who is the rival one? Montaneros. So the left-wing Peronist one. So politics now has
变得极其诡异和动荡。外国公司的管理人员不断遭到绑架和谋杀。1974年7月1日，庇隆再次突发心脏病。巫师当时也在场，据说他抓住庇隆的脚踝，含糊不清地念着某种咒语。但这一次，它失效了。他的法力抛弃了他。所以庇隆死了。巫师无法让他起死回生。
become extremely bizarre and troubled. Executives from foreign companies have been kidnapped and murdered all the time. Peron finally has another heart attack on the 1st of July, 1974. The warlock is there and he grabs, supposedly, Perron's ankles and mutters incomprehensibly a spell of some kind. But for once, it doesn't work. His powers have deserted him. So Perron is dead. The warlock can't bring him back to life.
我想，一个人只能复活有限的次数，这大概就是……我想是的。所以伊莎贝尔，一个夜总会舞者，现在成了阿根廷总统。通货膨胀率高达60%。恐怖主义暴行彻底失控。简直是首都。关于尸体依然有一些恶作剧在上演。
You can only bring people back so many times, I think, is the... I suppose, yeah. So Isabel, a nightclub dancer, is now president of Argentina. Inflation is 60%. Terrorist atrocities are totally out of control. It's capital. There are still some shenanigans with bodies.
因此，左翼游击队组织蒙托内罗斯在伊莎贝尔首次大型效忠日集会（10月17日）的前夕，偷走了第一位拿着信封的人——阿拉姆布鲁总统的尸体。他们偷走了他的尸体并说：“我们将扣留这具尸体，直到你们把艾薇塔的尸体带回来。”于是最终，整整一个月后，布宜诺斯艾利斯的街道被清空，武装警察守卫着机场，艾薇塔的尸体从马德里空运回来。所以艾薇塔的尸体现在回到了首都。现在，计划是将其安葬在由洛佩斯·雷加（即巫师）设计的巨大万神殿里，即祖国祭坛。
So the Montoneras, the left-wing guerrilla group, on the eve of Isabel's first big loyalty day rally, October the 17th, they stole the body of President Aramburu, the first man with the envelope. They stole his body and they say, we will keep this body until you bring back Evita's body. And so eventually, exactly a month later, the streets of Buenos Aires are cleared, armed police secure the airport, and Evita's body is flown in from Madrid. So Evita's body is now back in the capital. Now, the plan is that it will be buried in this huge pantheon designed by Lopez Rega, by the warlock, the altar of the fatherland.
但又一次，它被军事政变打乱了。所以这一次，首先，巫师被赶走了。军队对伊莎贝尔说，巫师必须走。但他那些魔法呢？托姆，它们毫无用处。我能说什么呢？他逃到国外并消失了。我想他隐居在西班牙和瑞士。
But yet again, it is overtaken by a military coup. So this time, first of all, the warlock is kicked out. The armies say to Isabel, the warlock's got to go. But what about his magic powers? They avail him naught, Tom. What can I say? He flees abroad and vanishes. He lived in hiding, I think, in Spain and Switzerland.
他娶了一位钢琴家。他把时间花在研究印度教上。然后在1986年，这太奇怪了。他们本可以拍一部伟大的网飞剧集之类的。我想实际上真的有一部关于这个的网飞剧集。他的妻子，那个钢琴家，以为所有人肯定都已经把他忘得一干二净了。所以她在迈阿密为他申请护照，以便他可以出行。你看，在此期间他的护照早就过期了。
He married a pianist. He spent his time writing about Hinduism. And then in 1986, this is so strange. They're going to make a great Netflix series or something. I think there is a Netflix series about this, actually. His wife, the pianist, decided that everyone must have forgotten about him. So she applied in Miami for him to get a passport so that he could travel. His passport had since expired, you see, in the interim.
她为他申请新护照，结果立刻在联邦调查局的系统中弹出了警示：此人因行刑队罪行、亡灵巫术、严重腐败和疯狂而在阿根廷遭到通缉。他被引渡回国，并在80年代末死于阿根廷的监狱中，但他实际上从未受审。所以这就是他的结局。难以置信的是，伊莎贝尔一直坚持到了1976年3月。她在一次军事政变中被推翻。我的意思是，有点像艾薇塔的尸体那样。他们把伊莎贝尔软禁了五年，因为他们不知道该拿她怎么办。
She applied for him to get a new passport and immediately came up on the fbi system this man is wanted in argentina for death squads necromancy gross corruption and madness and he was extradited and he died in prison in argentina at the end of the 80s but he never actually got to trial so that was the end of him isabel unbelievably she lasted until march 1976. She was toppled in a military coup. I mean, a bit like with Vita's body. They kept Isabel locked up under house arrest for five years because they couldn't work out what to do with her.
最后他们把她送回了马德里。滚吧。别再回来了。托姆，她有可能正在听这个播客，因为她还活着。她还活着。她93岁了。她还在世。哇。
And then eventually they sent her back to Madrid. Be off with you. Don't come back. Tom, it is possible she could be listening to this podcast because she is still alive. She's still alive. She's 93. She's still going. Wow.
吃蜂蜜就会这样，对吧？这就是蜂蜜的功效，我想如果你体内还有艾薇塔的生命之灵的话。确实如此。那么换个没那么好笑的话题，随着伊莎贝尔的倒台，军队掌权，他们试图打击恐怖分子的暴力行为以及诸如此类的事情。
That's what comes of eating honey, isn't it? It's the honey and I guess if you've, well, you've got the life spirit of Evita in you. That's true. So on a less amusing note, with Isabel's downfall, the army take power and they try and crack down on the terrorists' violence and all that kind of stuff.
他们发起了“肮脏战争”，我们在福克兰群岛的节目中讨论过。他们杀害了2万到3万人。现在电击棒的时代真的降临了。人们被从直升机上扔下去、遭到强奸、酷刑虐待。1982年，在绝望中，他们发起了他们的惊天赌博。他们占领了福克兰群岛。
They launch the Dirty War, which we talked about in our Falklands episodes. They killed between 20,000 and 30,000 people. Now you have the age of the cattle prod really is upon us. People being thrown out of helicopters, rape, torture. In 1982, in desperation, they launched their great gamble. They captured the Falkland Islands.
我必须说，结合当时的背景来看，你知道，他们袭击诸如赛马俱乐部这样的亲英文化中心，这似乎成了一个主题。所以在这一切结束时，其实只有一个线索需要收尾，那就是尸体。是的。所以新总统豪尔赫·维德拉（Jorge Videla）将军，即发动肮脏战争的维德拉将军，起初不肯搬进他的宫殿，因为那里现在有两个庇隆的尸体晃来晃去——不是将军本人吧，他被做成防腐处理了吗，还是有味道？我不知道，我假设他以某种方式做过防腐处理。艾薇塔也在那儿。这太诡异了。维德拉是个硬汉，他说，听着，我才不在那儿跟两具尸体住一起呢，这太疯狂了。所以他们最终同意把她移到
Which I have to say that that placed in context, you know, of them attacking Anglophile centres of culture, like the Jockey Club, seems to be a theme there. So at the end of all this, there was really only one strand to tie up, and that is the body. Yeah. So the new president, Jorge Videla, General Videla, who launches the Dirty War, he wouldn't move into his palace at first because they've now two perron bodies in there hanging around not the general well has he been embalmed or is he smelling or i don't i assume he'd been embalmed in some way evita is there as well that is so weird fidella who's a very hard man says look i'm not living there with two of them i mean that's mad so they eventually agreed that she would move to
1976年雷科莱塔公墓（Recolleta Cemetery）的一个家族墓穴中。雷科莱塔公墓是布宜诺斯艾利斯一个非常著名、看起来阴森恐怖的公墓，里面有着令人惊叹的各种华丽陵墓和纪念碑。当你去那里时——我的意思是去过那里——它并不是那种壮观的墓穴，她的名字在那里很小，只有一个小牌子，但故事是，墓穴的地板上有一个活板门，通往一个地下隔间，尸体就在那里。不，还有另一个活板门，通往另一个隔间，那里只有一把钥匙，通往第二个活板门的钥匙交给了艾薇塔的妹妹。那是能防范核导弹的钥匙吗？据说是的
a family vault in 1976 in the recollector cemetery which is the famous sort of very spooky looking cemetery amazing cemetery kind of these ornate tombs and memorials in buenos aires and when you go there i mean i've been there it's not one of the spectacular vaults and her name is quite small there's just a little plaque but the story is in the vault there is a trap door in the floor and that goes down to a subterranean compartment and that's where the body is no there's another trap door and that goes down to another compartment and there is only one key and the key to that second trapdoor was given to Evita's sister. And is that the one that is proof against a nuclear missile? Supposedly yeah
你不知道这是不是——谁知道呢，如果布宜诺斯艾利斯遭到核袭击，这可能是唯一能幸存下来的东西。正如艾薇塔的传记作家尼古拉斯·弗雷泽（Nicholas Fraser）和玛丽莎·纳瓦罗（Marisa Navarro）所说，它被放在那里，反映了一种恐惧，一种担心有一天尸体会在墓穴中消失，而那个女人——或者更准确地说，那个女人的神话——会再次出现。所以多米尼克，我的意思是，最后一个显而易见的问题。现在谁有钥匙？我就知道你会这么问。我不知道。哈维尔·米莱（Javier Milei）有钥匙吗？我的意思是，基本上，你知道吗？比起这一切背景下的疯狂闹剧，他挥舞着电锯的疯狂举动反而显得更容易理解了。
and you don't know whether this is I mean who knows if Buenos Aires was ever to come under nuclear attack this would be the one thing that would survive and as Evita's biographers Nicholas Fraser and Marisa Navarro say the fact that it is down there reflects a fear, a fear that one day that the body will disappear from the tomb and that the woman, or rather the myth of the woman, will reappear. So Dominic, I mean, one last obvious question. Who has the key now? I knew you'd ask that. I don't know. Does Javier Millet have the key? I mean, basically, do you know what? He seems so much more comprehensible with his chainsaw and his mad antics against the backdrop of all this.
也许他有钥匙，在某个时刻会打开它，然后艾薇塔的尸体就会出现来拯救她的子民。我想不出还有多少其他历史人物，亚历山大大帝可能是唯一一个你可以专门做一期节目来讲述他们的尸体、他们的政治意义，以及坦白说死后附着在尸体上的超自然意义的人物。这太让人联想起70年代的疯狂了，不是吗？是的。就像一部恐怖片。它具备了所有那些元素。我的意思是，我认为那个时期的电影主题和质量受到了政治的影响，但反过来，政治也许也受到了电影的影响。
Maybe he's got it and at some point will unlock it and the corpse of Evita will appear to save her people. I can't think of many other historical figures. Alexander is probably the only one where you could actually do an episode about their body and their sort of political significance and their, frankly, supernatural significance that's attached to the body after their death. It's so redolent of the madness of the 70s, isn't it? Yeah. It's like a horror film. It's got all those kind of elements. I mean, I suppose the themes and the
好吧，艾薇塔的政治理念受到了她成长过程中接触的探戈流行文化和肥皂剧的影响。贯穿始终的一个主题是政治与文化之间的交汇。但绝对没有——没有任何一档1940年代的广播肥皂剧会以如此诡异的戏剧性事件收场，就像巫师、尸体、蜂蜜、天使加百列以及所有那些事情一样。
quality of films in that period are informed by the politics, but also the politics perhaps is informed by the films. Well, Evita's politics were informed by the popular culture of the tango and the soap operas that she'd grown up with. A theme throughout this is the interface between politics and culture. But there's no way, there's no radio soap opera of the 1940s that ends with such a bizarre twist of events as that business with the warlock, the body, the honey, the angel Gabriel and all that stuff.
我的意思是，谁也没料到会这样。多么奇怪的故事啊。一个非常非常奇怪的故事。非常感谢你，多米尼克，讲了这么多。真的，一个精彩绝伦的故事。所以我们希望大家都喜欢它。多米尼克，非常感谢。再见。
I mean, nobody saw that coming. What a strange story. A very, very strange story. Thank you so much, Dominic, for all that. Absolutely, I mean, amazing story. So we hope you've all enjoyed it. Dominic, thanks ever so much. And hasta luego.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》，这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、精彩的娱乐圈八卦。
Hasta luego. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家附赠节目
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。